sin vi cómo transcurrió la jornada o
alguna denuncia de irregularidades
fue una jornada bastante calma las
irregularidades reportadas al tribunal
supremo electoral fueron menores con
excepción quizá de un caso de un
simpatizante del candidato rodrigo
chávez que envió mensajes de textos a
los fiscales de mesa en todo el país
advirtiéndoles sobre las sanciones
penales por posibles delitos electorales
el mensaje fue calificado por el
tribunal como intimidatorio a una
analiza el caso mientras que este
simpatizante asegura que lo hizo
únicamente como un recordatorio para los
agentes electorales además de eso un
caso sin precedentes el lamentable
fallecimiento de un votante una persona
mayor de 76 años que sufrió un infarto
tras haber emitido su voto unos segundos
después de haber emitido su voto la
organización de estados américanos que
observó la elección también dijo que no
observó ningún tipo de anomalía
destacable
y a qué hora se espera que se empiecen a
conocer resultados
los resultados se empezarán a dar a
partir de las 20 horas local y en ese
momento se dará un acto solemne en el
tribunal supremo electoral y
posteriormente empezarán a liberarse los
resultados el primer corte se espera que
contenga al menos el 14 por ciento de
los votos contados de las distintas
juntas receptoras de votos y luego de
esos cada 10-15 minutos estarán
actualizando con un mayor número de
votos finalmente luego para el martes 5
de abril se espera que se haga un
escrutinio final de la votación sin
embargo los resultados de esta noche
serán lo suficientemente fiables como
para determinar un ganador